commit to getting more done the more you
get done the more you will earn I think
people's dreams are one of the things
holding them back because they don't
know how to drink the information you
have is wrong the wealthy talk
differently than the middle-class need
motivation watch the top 10 with believe
nation
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being a kid labeled with a DD
struggling with drug addictions and
almost dying to becoming a multiple time
best-selling author
top sales expert and owning over half a
billion dollars in real estate
he's Grant Cardone and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 13 also
if you want to know a grant and other
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you have to go
build self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one never give up I lost my dad when I
was 10 I lost my brother when I was 20 I
lost you know I gave up my career and
maybe I'm gonna be a baseball player to
drugs I've lost five or six jobs now and
I'm a loser I'm a total loser but I do
have this little this little light
inside of me it says I'm special I have
this little thing inside of me and says
hey you you are special you know you
have something but it was just covered
up and all this stuff and all these
problems and in the drugs and the bad
friends and the bad choices so my mom
finally says enough is enough don't come
back here anymore I'm done I could tell
it was hard for her I'm in a treatment
center in the next 24 hours I go to this
treatment center I'm there thirty days
for the first thirty days and seven
eight nine years I don't use drugs oh
wow I don't have to use drugs finally
that thing where I said I was quitting
ten times a day I was quitting ten times
a day for the first time in my life I
was able to quit successfully I'm
leaving the treatment center when the
insurance ran out because that's how
those work when the money runs out they
boot you to the curb I'm terrified
scared to go back to society I don't
have any friends that aren't using drugs
my girlfriend was using drugs everybody
around me everybody I knew use drugs and
I'm going back to a job where even at
the job I had they use drugs and I'm
like I'm going back to an environment I
have to cut off all my friends not
really friends I got to cut off all the
enemies right and I got to start over
and before I leave the counselor grabs
me and the counselor says to me look
dude I'll see you back here probably you
know if you don't die I'll see you back
here and I'm like what are you talking
about dude I'm not coming back here and
he's like oh no you're coming back and
then he gives me the lecture he's like
you'll never make it
see when you go to a treatment center
you tell them everything about your life
like all your secrets all your your your
inhibitions and and your you know the
things you want to do in your life right
and so I'm telling them in this thing
everything I've done everything I've
done wrong I share my whole life but I
also share with them what I want to do
my inspiration in life I'm going to
write books I'm going to speak to
audiences I'm gonna help people I'm
gonna tell people this story about drugs
and how damaging they are and I'm gonna
be somebody I tell them and they're like
you're a drug addict and all you're ever
gonna be to split the counselor tells
all you're ever gonna be is a drug
addict you need to give up all the ideas
of writing books speak into audiences
being rich I always wanted to be rich I
wanted financially to be rich but I
wanted to be my dad I wanted to be the
guy that could take care of his family
they said you need to give up all those
ideas and settle for one thing not using
drugs if the day ends and you don't use
drugs grant that is a good day for you
rule number two think bigger
I just got awarded awarded this deal
ninety two point five million dollars 31
acres land you know my buddy Evan
Carmichael talks about dream belief yeah
but dream what and believe what believe
you pay your bills I believe you can one
day write a check for sixty million
bucks what do you believe what are you
gonna dream of like literally I think
people's dreams are one of the things
holding them back because they don't
know how to dream I don't know how big
the dream this is doable for any person
I don't care who you are
anybody could do this deal anybody could
do that deal I know the guys that own
private jet
then they're smarter than anybody else
they're not smaller they don't work
probably don't even work any harder but
they did they did think bigger and they
get in the end and you can't you can't
catch whales in it in up in a bowl
goldfish bubble so you got to be in the
right in the right stream traffic rule
number three get attention money follows
attention money follows attention how
much attention can you guys get okay
most of you can't get attention because
your mom and daddy said don't get too
much attention don't get too much
attention be seen and not heard
fly under the radar because if you get
too much attention they're gonna shoot
you down right how many hurtness before
time to the radar man
stay low man don't let anybody see you
making moves don't make moves man don't
make moves and then everybody wonders
why can't I get above because you don't
get attention
strangers have everything you want
everything you want a stranger has it it
will be strangers that will grow your
business it will be strangers that put
your kids through schools it will be
strangers that make your dreams a
reality
strangers have everything you want but
you were taught not to talk to them
rule number four change your thinking we
can't afford that how many you told your
kids with that before we can't do that
bike we can't buy the bike right you
told your kids that cuz you were told
that right we don't tell our kids that
how many of you were told this kids be
careful that's why you guys think so
much you got yet Dave Ramsey on TV
saying total freedom comes from not
having debt okay you got you you flip
channels and you go to Suze you can't
afford that okay I'm gonna tell you do
you can afford anything
[Music]
hey debts not your problem okay I got
four four I got I probably got five
hundred million dollars worth of debt
today five hundred million I wish it was
five billion rule number five get busy
yeah man I had to get over drugs went to
treatment center spent 28 days in a
treatment center no it's 25 my mom my
brother my sister all gave up on me like
their luck I enough that's how bad of
trouble obviously no he's using was
using drugs every 45 minutes I wasn't
using drug once or twice a day I was
using once or twice an hour whatever
you're not gonna do the business be you
probably shouldn't be doing the period
so I had to clean up I had to clean up
my deal man 28 days I got 28 days first
28 days of my life in seven years that I
didn't use drugs I was like man what am
I gonna do now my fear what using drugs
me my fear was what am I gonna do with
all my time so when you see me run right
now I'm running from one thing to the
next thing I'm trying to stay busy cuz
as long as I stay busy I don't get in
trouble by the way I'm the guy that
couldn't pay his rent
$275 a month in rent rule number six
study wealthy people so a 25 re
committed to my education but this time
I started studying not things that were
in books but people that had actually
created wealth not people that had made
money but people that he created wealth
this is completely different I was no
longer studying accounting and economics
I was studying wealthy people and only
wealthy people I'm not talking about the
doctor that was a neighbor that makes a
million dollars a year and he's working
18 hours a day and he hates his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with Pam I'm
talking about the yacht people I'm
talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation I'm talking about the car
dealer that had 28 car dealerships are
82 car dealerships that has in
disposable money I'm talking about the
Walton money I'm talking about with the
Waltons last week increase their net
worth by 11 billion dollars and they
haven't worked for 30 years
that's the kind of wealth I started
study I started reading Barron's in The
Wall Street Journal and I quickly
realized something
that the wealthy people had financial
freedom and no one else did okay a very
small percentage of people lots of
people have money
my uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money
wouldn't spend it acted like a miser
buried money in the backyard I realized
my parents had it wrong the information
I had that was wrong and this is the
number one thing I want you to get out
of tonight the information you have is
wrong the wealthy talk differently than
the middle-class I watch my mom and my
dad I started comparing the wealthy
people to what my dad did my dad worked
every day every day of the week if he
wasn't working at the office he was
working in the yard they saved money
they cut their own grass okay
we ate all our food we turned the lights
off we didn't waste anything
and that was uncertainty was insecurity
in a sphere and it perpetuated
uncertainty insecurity and fear and and
all the lessons about money money
doesn't grow on trees a penny saved is a
penny earned eat all your food people
are starving okay
money money you don't waste it don't
play with it all that creates insecurity
and it's incorrect rule number seven
come in you just got to say I'm going to
get more done and quit talking about all
this BS that you're telling yourself I
don't have time I don't have time I
ain't got time I'm tired
it don't matter man commit to getting
more done the more you get done the more
you will earn period in the story right
so I get more done than Elena does Elena
Elena said here right now she would say
this man is a damn machine why do I get
more done because I post I post without
looking at it I simply get more done why
because I'm committed to getting more
done I'm not I'm not committed to doing
it perfectly rule number eight change
yourself if you want things to change
they can change and they're not gonna
change this because you pray just
because you wish just cuz you hope and
they won't change this cuz your family
wants it and change it it did not change
it's still until I started getting
information and if you take your notes
today it didn't start changing until I
started getting rid of information one
of the most important things that
happened to me in my life was to get rid
of information a man told me once he's
like hey look man if things don't go
well somebody or something is causing it
not to go well how many agree with that
statement
okay things aren't going well something
or someone is causing things not to go
well okay and before you guys take on
the Republicans or the Democrats or the
conspiracy he said grant before you take
on other people once you just take on
these 24 inches right here but before
you take on change in the whole world
once you handle like between your
shoulders cuz you got your hands full
rule number 9 execute on ideas different
game today folks different game man
everything's changing remember when you
waited for a taxi cab remember that when
was that how many people in this planet
complained about having to wait on a
dirty cab millions and millions and
millions of people said oh my gosh hey
man let's just send it to them if you
can close the distance between an idea
in money's okay
you'll get rich and real number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is find your drive when I was a kid
when I was growing up the guy that the
guy that knew how to take care of his
environment was my dad
I was eight years old and then this dude
just do controlled everything in this
environment
and he left early for work he came home
late
took care of his family how that you
knew he never gave anybody a lecture
about what to do he just let he was a
good example
and
and he had the money and he made the
money we were middle club middle-class
families so we were like little red
brick house white brick actually white
brick house about 1,400 square feet
seven people lived in it and my dad I
could tell my dad was trying to get
somewhere he was trying to move us up he
was trying and he wasn't trying to brag
he was trying to take care of
and so I was watching that right and I
watched where this guy he he's the one
that made the decision where we went how
long we stayed and I started associating
that the moneymaker makes the rules
this is what Elena was talking about you
know there's around the money I make the
rules around the money around other
things Elena makes the rules so you got
to know what you're good at what your
job is and what your role is my dad and
my mom knew their roles problem with
that is when my dad died suddenly at 52
years old my mom was left to do
something she didn't she didn't have it
she was not skilled up to do
and and I was 10 and I wasn't I didn't
know how to help my mom
and my dad left a little bit of
insurance money from the from the life
insurance or the death insurance better
better it's really called death
insurance just can't sell it if they
call it that and my mom didn't know how
long that money would last so
immediately after my dad died when my
what mom should have been in grief she
would win immediately into massive fear
and I could see it I could sense it as a
ten year old my mom was in fear every
day clipping coupons saving money you
know turn the lights off eat all your
food it was constant messages go across
town to get gas like everything came by
strawberries today you know there'll be
there'll be 20 cents cheaper tomorrow
everything was about
fear
and so I I couldn't do anything about it
or didn't think I could do anything
about it and I just kept telling myself
one day one day I'ma be in a position to
change this and I think that really
drives me today to like take care of
people not be in that situation again
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with grant on how to just move that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point lighting questions time to move
from just watching another video to
taking action in your life for business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answer in the comments below here we go
question number one what ideas do you
need to start executing on number two
which three wealthy people will you
commit to studying and number three
what's the think bigger version of your
idea
the boy right here my buddy dummy right
here never moves
he's coming hit on him as much as you
want slapping reminds me of the first
like 25 years of my life
this right here I just take it never
moved but I look good
wouldn't read just a damn dummy boom
don't be that dude
if you want more grant checking my top
50 rules video on him I think you'll
enjoy the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there don't watch the news decide when
you leave here today to make the news
you don't get attention today you have
absolutely zero chance of being
successful